and taking the mound for the texas
rangers tonight is the right-hander
veteran right-hander jordan lyles he's
making his 13th start you see the
numbers not pretty
5-7-5 era and he gets a swing gonna miss
for strike three so he strikes out wade
and we are underway tonight
a swing at a miss and
right now lyle's commanding the breaking
ball
and two strikeouts to get it started
he delivers and that one is lobbed up in
the air to short right center
in comes joey gallo he says he has it
and he does
it's an easy one two three top of the
first for jordan
horton lyles taking the mound tonight
for the giants in arlington will be the
left-hander alex wood veteran's been
around for a while making his tent start
really good numbers who got off to a hot
start 5-0 brandon crawford
took the field and found out that he was
the only one
and then he he looked back to see where
everybody else was and
and then he kind of smiled at it as he
took the field
establishing the all-time franchise
record in the 139th year of giants
baseball ford
games played by a shortstop here's jose
counterfell for hitting 284
up the middle base head on the 13th
pitch of the at-bat
here's a swing and a ball lined to
second solano catches the throw to first
and it doubles up connor falefa
how about that alex wood will take it
calhoun hit a liner
and kiner falefa i don't know if he
didn't freeze or what
he actually took two full strides
towards second base
off the bat and once solano caught it i
mean
it wasn't easy but that was a relatively
simple double play
and here's brandon belt just off the
injured list
and that's a walk here is brandon
crawford no
ball four two straight walks by lyles to
start the inning
runners off first and second base and
this one on the ground third base
culvers in the second one onto first
got him the only question was did low
keep a
a toe on the bag and apparently he did
and they get the double play
runner at third two down right to freak
and off the glove
of low and the run scores
nate lowe who was never known for his
defense
and that cost the rangers a run right
there joey hitting 207
10 homers and 26 runs batted in gallows
swings and belts when to deep right
field
this is well hit and that ball is
history this game is tied
a line drive home run straightaway right
it's the 11th of the year for joey gallo
the 131st of his career
and he's now the all-time leader in home
runs at globe life field that's his
ninth
we're tied at one bossler is on for
buster posey now
2-2 this one lined over short that's a
base hit
posey's hot bat stays that way giants
have a couple of base runners here in
the third
one two pitch in that one lined out into
right field that's a base hit
fossler around third he's coming to the
plate here's a throw from gallo and they
got him at home anything is over
another outfield assist for gallow his
third of the year
they must not have had an advanced scout
to watch the tampa bay series
or they would have held them up at third
well to bring up posey
posey has fly to right and single to
left center
that's hit in the air to deep right
field gallow angling back toward the
corner
veers sharply toward the corner to his
left and makes the catch
posey is out and so are the giants
charlie culverson
stepping in now he walked in the second
oh might have gotten
culverson i think he did on his foot and
so he'll head to first
trying to throw the slider down and in
and maybe get a swing and a miss at it
but he
yanked it a little too far in and ended
up hitting culverson with it
and trevino steps in he's all for one
on the ground this could be two again
how many times have we seen brandon
crawford
turn a double play like that just
beautiful here's brandon crawford
he has walked and clied out to left
field and now that this is an official
ball game
we've completed five innings crawford is
officially the
giants record holder for games played at
shortstop
lyles with the 1-0 pitch that one is hit
to right center field very well hit
it is gone he did it right over 374
13th of the year for brandon crawford to
put the giants ahead
good for brandon crawford waiting on
something centered
103. got every stitch of that baseball
i mean that is hard hit launch angles
not super high just hits an absolute
rocket and now calhoun he was lined into
the double play and grounded into
a desert fight there goes and there's
ball four to calhoun
second walk in the inning rangers have a
couple of base runners now
including the tying run out there in
scoring position
3-2 and that one down the line that's a
base hit
kiner falefa will score calhoun hustling
to third base
and el bumby has tied the game in the
sixth inning with a double to left
he gets a change up that basically
finishes
middle of the plate just a little bit
above the knees and he's able to hit it
hard enough to get it by flora
3-2 and he misses in so they are loaded
up
a chance for nick solak to deliver a big
hit
this ball lined out to left field that
will get down base hit
calhoun is in garcia on his heels he'll
score
into second base with a two-run double
solac is giving the rangers a two-run
lead
that ball wasn't a strike but nick got
it anyway
right down the left field line a little
bit off the handle but a well-placed
huge double for the rangers
to give them a 4-2 lead joely rodriguez
comes into a pretty big spot here in the
seventh inning solano at third
lamont wade junior the runner at first
base and one out
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
slater
and they're two away that's a huge
strikeout for the rangers
huge strikeout for rodriguez like a
slider right at the bottom of the zone
change up actually you see him turn it
over with the last three fingers
zero two and a swing and a miss
rodriguez
back-to-back strikeouts to get the
rangers out of trouble in the seventh
four to two the giants are trailing but
they had the bases loaded with one out
and donovan solano to face
josh spores this one line to short
caught out there by kiner falefa for the
second out of the inning
that was our rope kind of checking his
hand out after that one
and now talkman down the right field
line deep into the corner
it's a grand slam mike talkman with a
laser beam into the right
field corner for a grand slam to turn
this game around
and the giants are ahead six to four
what a moment for chalkman wow
what a time to come up huge what a time
to come up huge
a couple of base runners brandon
crawford
crawford deep right field way back there
his second home run in the game
and now the giants have a big lead
posey scores belt scores and crawford
will cross
to make it nine to four giants and now
dominic leone would try and wrap this
one up for the giants
in the last of the ninth and that
puts an end to it white goes down on
strikes two strikeouts in the inning
and mike talkman is the man
the grand slam that turned it all around
for the giants in the eighth inning
and they win this one on the night that
brandon crawford sets an all-time giants
record for games played at shortstop